[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24 y
ya está conmigo en el estudio marina
sardina marina bienvenida buena mañana
de viernes hoy vamos a hablar de la
polémica en torno al llamado impuesto
saludable que el nuevo gobierno
colombiano busca implementar en el país
esto para mitigar dice las consecuencias
negativas para la salud de los
colombianos como impuesto también a las
bebidas azucaradas y alimentos suelta
procesados marina hacia raúl y lo vamos
a tratar con un enfoque de salud pública
tú sabes que es un ultra procesado por
ejemplo pues me imagino los embutidos y
ese tipo de alimentos así es según la o
ms raúl los ultra procesados son el
motor de la epidemia de obesidad en
américa latina se tratan de alimentos
que están procesados industrialmente
como su nombre lo indica bebidas
azucaradas comida rápida que está
desplazando las dietas tradicionales más
nutritivas por ejemplo raúl la malta que
tú te tomabas en venezuela no la gaseosa
flor de organización mundial de la salud
recomienda reducir el consumo de azúcar
al 5 por ciento de la ingesta calórica
diaria unos 25 gramos al día
esa misma malta que tú te tomas según la
bp ese contiene 8 veces más la cantidad
récord nada de azúcares libres las
consecuencias para nuestra salud de este
exceso de azúcares y calorías de nuestro
cuerpo son devastadoras claro marina y
digamos que enfermedad entonces se
deberían de ese tipo de alimentación
basada en los alimentos ultra procesados
o cargados de azúcares libres además
como lo llamas bueno son enfermedades
que si bien este tipo de azúcar es una
de las causas son multicausales no pero
una mala alimentación hace más propicia
el desarrollo de estas mismas
enfermedades por ejemplo en colombia
donde el departamento administrativo
nacional de estadística el dane dice que
casi el 62 por ciento de los colombianos
acepta consumir estos productos ultra
procesados seis de cada diez colombianos
padecen obesidad que es la principal
causa de muerte cada año en el mundo
según la oms 28 millones de personas el
37 75 de los adultos entre 18 y 64 años
en colombia padecen sobrepeso y 16
millones de personas padecen diabetes en
2019 más de 38 mil personas fallecieron
por enfermedades y comen música
del corazón y más de 15.000 por
enfermedades cerebrovasculares
unas cifras que debería alarmarnos por
eso hablamos previamente con diana
trejos ella es nutricionista y miembro
de la asociación colombiana de nutrición
clínica
el abuso de alimentos ultra procesados y
altos en azúcar era una consecuencia
sumamente negativa para la salud y es el
desarrollo de enfermedades como el
sobrepeso la obesidad y secundariamente
a estas la diabetes la hipertensión y en
general muchas enfermedades
cardiovasculares son medidas que no son
populares y en eso tenemos supremamente
claro las asociaciones de nutrición como
la asociación colombiana de nutrición
clínica en que cuando hablamos muchas
veces de los temas de nutrición siempre
se relaciona que vamos a quitar comida
tenemos que decir que vamos a ofrecer
alimentos sanos comer sano y es algo que
deben entender todos es mucho más
económico económico es mucho más barato
que comer mal
que genera el azúcar en nuestro cuerpo
bueno raúl un exceso de estos azúcares
libres que veníamos hablando puede
generar un aumento de peso de la presión
y de la presión arterial puesto que
nuestro cuerpo absorbe rápidamente estos
azúcares al aumentando bruscamente la
glucosa en sangre y liberando insulina
en grandes cantidades lo que estimula el
almacenamiento de grasas también puede
generar malnutrición riesgo de alzhéimer
problemas dentales dentales como caries
o acné también hablamos con la doctora
al respecto cuando tú con los alimentos
ultra procesados o altos en azúcar en la
primera parte de nuestro sistema
digestivo a nivel intestinal se absorben
muy rápido es decir nos llegan a ser un
proceso digestivo normal que ocupe todas
las partes de nuestro sistema intestinal
y hay partes que si no se tocan si no
les llega fibras no les llega cierto
tipo de alimentos como las frutas las
verduras y los granos no producen unas
sustancias necesarias para regular
metabólicamente en nuestro organismo
entonces cómo se absorben tan rápido
estos en la primer parte del duodeno y
pedazo del yeyuno que es la parte más
inicial del intestino delgado
se absorben tan rápido y a lo es entran
tan rápido en las células porque no
requieren mayor proceso eso estimula la
ganancia de peso en nuestras células
grasas y a su vez cómo se absorben tan
rápido nos da hambre más rápido
marín entonces ante todo esto que pues
evidentemente es dañino para nuestra
porque surgen estas polémicas cuando los
países intentan paliar digamos estas
enfermedades a través de los impuestos
bueno es que el lobby de los ultra
procesados es poderosísimo en todo el
mundo pero como dicen los nutricionistas
comer de forma saludable es mucho más
económico si simplemente hace falta que
estas medidas vayan acompañadas de
campañas educativas una alimentación
sana también reduce los costos más de
salud públicos pero además también es un
tema de soberanía alimentaria la doctora
nos hablaba de recuperar productos que
son muy comunes en la región como la
papa la yuca frutas y verduras que se
encuentran aquí en américa latina' y
volver a las plazas de mercado esto es
lo que nos recomiendo mirar cuando
hablamos de soberanía alimentaria
hablamos también de inseguridad y mental
y la inseguridad alimentaria no es
solamente la falta de alimentos sino la
falta de educación para seleccionar
alimentos adecuados y en eso creo que es
la resistencia que más encontramos en
este momento en los programas con
general de salud de todos los gobiernos
viven estimular la prevención de
desarrollo de enfermedades este tipo de
medidas lo que busca es evitar es tratar
de evitar que las personas de alguna
forma consuman alimentos que son dañinos
y perjudiciales para su salud
con esto no queremos decir que vamos a
afectar el tipo de dieta la población
que se va a ver afectada no lo que
queremos es enseñar este tipo de medidas
y en muchos países no han tenido el
éxito que deberían tener porque no van
acompañadas de medidas de educación
marina como siempre gracias a por toda
esta valiosísima información de la
crónica de salud de hoy nos vemos el
lunes con más salud por supuesto y
pasamos a saludar en nuestro segundo
invitado el día